well jeopardy airs its final five  episodes  with the late great alex trebek this  week and last night  another great canadian ryan reynolds  joined the show to offer this  movie clue let's do the movies for 600.  all right i'm ryan reynolds in my 2020  movie free guy  i play a bank teller who comes to  realize that he's really an  npc short for this kind of character  in an open world video game guy in two  days the game is gonna shut down  you this whole city they'll be gone what  if we can save it  is that cool it felt really cool ryden  was a non-player character you are right  and after the game show posted that clip  on twitter ryan responded with his own  tweet writing  it's an honor and a little heartbreaking  to be with alex trebek one last time  on jeopardy and we'll see alex and ryan  together again  when the game show legend makes a cameo  and ryan's often delayed free guy  adventure which is now scheduled to  finally arrive this may